What
for
being
[Silence]
a
ever
They're
rel
to
Heck
is in
[Silence]
whatever it is.
A wolf can
I slap
can I do to make up for this
this transgression?
So the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
said bring her. So he brought the girl.
This is a slave girl. Okay. This is a
servant. This is not even extended
family.
And the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
said
Allah where is Allah? She said he is
above.
He said
she said you are the messenger of Allah.
he said she is a believer. So
free her, give her her her freedom.
In turn the point of the narration that
one of the points that the scholars
point out of this narration is that we
see that this girl
probably had never even met the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam before that day,
before that moment.
Yet
whatever Muawia was learning he was
teaching even to his slaves
because these are our responsibilities.
So when we go into topics of
menration and postpartum etc. We don't
necessarily suffer from these things
ourselves or say suffer but you know
we don't we don't we don't
necessarily encounter these things
ourselves but we are responsible for our
women knowing what is obligated upon
them and what is not and if your wife or
your daughter or your sister etc
is not worshiping Allah based on
knowledge knowledge that is largely your
fault. That is largely my fault. That is
largely our fault. The male who is
responsible for her will be held to
account for that as well. So it's
important that we focus on these things.
menration and postpartum. Menration I
think we understand it's a monthly cycle
usually monthly.
Postpartum is after
birth. After a woman gives birth,
there's what is called postpartum. Post
meaning after, pardon meaning birth.
Postpartum, I think it's Latin or
something. bleeding and that is that
the womb now from this nine months of
you know carrying this child and and and
carrying this child to term now the womb
is being cleared out right and so a
woman may experience bleeding or
spotting and for a number of days or
even weeks
and in the legislation of Islam up to 40
days. Anything beyond 40 days is no
longer considered to be postpartum.
So the longest a woman will experience
postpartum bleeding is 40 days. Anything
beyond that
is not considered postpartum bleeding in
Islam.
It may be medically, right? But in
Islamic legislation, she now is to make
voodoo for each salah and pray even if
she is still having this bleeding. Now
in the legislation of Islam,
menration and postpartum bleeding have
the same rulings in everything except
for three issues.
except for three
three points or three
scenarios
where Islam differentiates between
ministration and postpartum. When we say
three issues, we're speaking about
things divorce and so forth. But
the
essence or the norm for menration and
postpartum is they are the same. What
applies to this applies to that. What
applies to ministration applies to
postpartum. What applies to postpartum
applies to ministration.
In all things in Islamic law except for
three things.
Fasting is not one of them. So whatever
applies to a woman with respect to
fasting
in menration applies in postpartum.
Okay. So when a woman is on her cycle,
she does not fast. It's not permissible
for her to fast. not only is the fast
invalid, but it's not permissible for
her to fast.
So a woman will not fast while she is on
her cycle. Once her cycle is completed,
she will make those days up later. If
she is as well in a state of postpartum,
she as well will not fast. It has the
same exact ruling.
forch.
[Silence]
And the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam tells us in the narration of
Bkari
that a woman
when she is upon her
cycle her monthly cycle or monthly
she does not pray and she does not fast.
And he said this in the form of a
question
which means that this places this in the
realm of common knowledge right when you
ask a question if I say for instance is
this not the case that means that it's
it's more it's more it's more
of a strong it's a stronger statement as
a question as a rhetorical question than
it is as a statement because when it
comes in the form of a rhetorical
question it means it's common knowledge.
This is something that every Muslim
knows.
So when a woman is on her cycle she does
not pray and she does not fast.
Now this mentions monthly cycle.
Where do we get postpartum from? We said
the principle is that postpartum and
menration has the same ruling always
except in three issues and this is not
one of them. He says
[Silence]
Muslim.
And in Sah Muslim the author says
that if a woman is upon her menstrual
cycle or having postpartum bleeding and
she were to fast hypothetically
this fast will not be valid and this is
something that is agreed upon. This is
an issue of consensus amongst the
scholars of Islam
because one of the conditions of fasting
is that a woman be a woman be pure of
menration or postpartum when she
fasts. And a woman is to make up her
fast.
she is to make up her fast that she
misses while she is on her cycle or
during her postpartum. He then cites a
narration collected by Imam Muslim
in his authentic compilation on the
authority of
the prophet's wife.
You know asbal mentions in
fat he says that is responsible
for
transmitting
1/4th of all of the legislation of Islam
is responsible for the transmission of
up to a fourth of the legislation of
Islam. This is incredible, right?
especially when you know that when
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
died, she was how old? Anyone know?
18 years old.
You compare that to an 18year-old today
can barely figure out how to erase his
search history.
However, 18 years old she is. She is
transmitting
1/4th of the legislation of Islam.
Says we meaning the women used to
experience our cycle in the time of the
messenger of Allah saiam.
And we would be commanded to
make up our fast that we missed. and we
would not be commanded to make up our
salah that we missed. This is a huge a
huge relief from Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala because fasting might be a day or
two or up to a week or maybe even 10
days. However, if a woman were to have
to make up her salah
for
five or 10 days, right, times five, this
would be a huge burden. And so because
of that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
allowed them that during their cycle
something that is not in their control
they do not have to make up the salah
that they miss but they do have to make
up the fasting that they miss.
Subhan Allah.